john-paul stone art trained as a painter
the Courtauld Institute completing a PhD
on art in post Second World War Germany
in 2005 since published as faultlines
art in Germany 1945 to 1955 he has
worked as an adjunct lecturer at the
Courtauld Institute and also as a
contributing editor to the Burlington
Mad Magazine in 2010 he was made a
senior fellow at the Center for Advanced
Study in the visual arts at the National
National Gallery of Art in Washington
more recently he curated the exhibition
Kenneth Clark looking for civilization
at Tate Britain and Germany divided
basslets and his generation at the
British Museum he is currently working
as a freelance scholar in London please
join me in welcoming John Paul stoner
well thank you very much Sophie for that
very kind introduction and it's a real
pleasure to be here and echo the thanks
of my fellow speakers to the organizers
and it's really been such a beautifully
organized conference I mean it's become
a kind of a work of art in itself so and
I should also thank Tim who invited me
to speak in the first place to America
and my first thought and I think his
intention was that I should be speaking
about Kenneth Clarke having been
involved in this exhibition to take
Britain and I suppose I should start by
apologizing for not doing so and it
would seem an obvious choice because
Clarke is of course the great beacon of
culture and in Britain during the Second
World War and even has some connections
with America however I've instead chosen
to talk about an unknown 15-year old
with no interest in art who was still
living at home with his parents when war
broke out David Sylvester and so here
they are and the photograph on the of
Sylvester Allman right and it comes
without a date but I'm assuming this
around 1945 and as you can see is 20
years younger than Clarke so still a
teenager during the war so I thought to
better explain why I've taken
approach and I think the first thing is
to say that really and Sylvester was
becoming a critic Hritik during this
time and was in touch with the younger
generation of artists so he obviously
kind of a less of an institutional
points of view on what was happening and
it's very interesting to watch him forge
his career as not a critic during this
period and and also America came to have
a very important place in his life and
work slightly later on and I think
within what you could call of late
modernism he became a kind of
transatlantic negotiator and I think
it's also true to say that this was
something that was being forged during
the Second World War these the kind of
terms of these negotiations were being
laid out and the other occasion to talk
about Sylvester is that his who died in
2002 so I'll just check that 2001 sorry
he is that his archives went to take
gallery and they've just been catalogues
they're not quite open but it's possible
to look at them and they're incredibly
interesting and has lots of really
extraordinary material in there
including drafts of his unpublished
memoirs in fact a bit of the memoirs
published as a book called memoirs with
pet lamb which is wonderful to read and
it covers his childhood but the war
years and there's a lot of material
which hasn't been published so it's all
there to be and looked at and kind of
picked over and thought about and and my
idea really was to follow sylvester
around London during the Blitz and after
reading have almost like walking after
him seeing where he was going and who he
was meeting and and trying to perhaps to
think about and how that informed his
later career so the story begins in 1941
the seventeen-year-old so vested living
in with his parents in Wellington
quarter block of flats in st. John's
Wood Oskar Kokoschka could live just
next door that's a bit of a footnote but
anyway he'd left school without
qualifications he was doing various jobs
and hanging around pubs and bars in Soho
and wondering what to do him themselves
so he's a kind of dangling man is it
now the moment of the very important
moment is which he talks about in the
memoirs is this moment where he
discovered a through two reproductions
Matisse's a dance in a Robert
goldwater's book primitivism in modern
art on the left and francis Bacon's
crucifixion which was famously
illustrated in the Herbert Reed's 1933
art now book and and his immediate
response to this was to become a painter
now none of his paintings survived which
is probably quite fortunate he changed
his name to Richard Sylvester operably
Shas invest which is I suppose what you
do have you're 18 and you want to become
a painter you change your name to
something painfully pretentious and then
went at it and painted as France no for
a year and then had one notable success
which was a garage called Hecate II
which was exhibited at Jack Bilbo's
gallery modern art gallery on Baker
Street at the end of 1942 and I put this
up now I don't know how much you know
about Jack Bilbo he was a german german
jewish immigrant kind of impresario who
ended up in london in and opened a an
art gallery in 1941 and had
extraordinary exhibitions of katherine
Schwitters and also young British
artists Oh Sylvester Rashad Sylvester
was part of this and I think it's
Sylvester his style was probably quite
similar to Bill about so I put this up
to give some indication of perhaps what
Sylvester was doing just as another
footnote Jack Bilbo's autobiography
published in 1948 is vast tome and it's
a massive monument to his ego and really
wonderful book to read and the more I
used to think his paintings were
disastrous and not worth looking at but
the more I look at them the more I like
them I still think my disastrous but
there's something really engaging about
them and he was showing during the war
so on the right there's an photographs
of his exhibition at reading the fair
for a gallery in January 43 so having
some success maybe only more time done
to get this take place
so the Rashaad Sylvester is and David
Sylvester's career seemed to be going
somewhere but then Erika browsin who was
the working at Redfern ground gallery
she became a very important gallery
staff
told him you'll never be a painter stop
painting so he did and I think then
after bird told his works of art but the
reason was spirit is important it's the
moment when he's he launches himself
into the art world and he goes who meets
lots of young artists and sees lots of
exhibitions and so he can weave in
perhaps gonna try and could have put
together what he was looking at and
there's a very interesting interview he
did late in life with Richard Falk I'm
where he talks about this period in
quite some detail so and I just put up a
few other things inventions he talks
about seeing Epstein's Jacob and the
angel I'm not sure if he saw it at Tate
but it was I don't have ended the story
but after it was shown that Tate it was
then taken around the country on a kind
of Kong in your tour as a kind of horror
a sensational thing and on the right
there's the display that in Oxford
Street in bombed-out Oxford Street in
1946 anyway this is one of the things
that struck Sylvester at the time he
also survive on Hitchens first one-man
exhibition solo exhibition of the
Leicester galleries in 1942 and he would
have seen this extraordinary painting
view from terrace Ashdown Forest which
is now in the collection of Tate he
would have seen he saw this painting or
the butterfly night by Matisse which was
displayed at the region of F galleries
and I think you have to somehow imagine
the extraordinary impact of this in and
of the the gray and black blacked out
London how extraordinary this can this
kind of painting would have appeared and
it's no surprise he remembered it so he
was going seeing all these walking
around out under seeing these
exhibitions they were a lot more so
that's just a brief indication but by
late this dome like captures it being
cut off sorry about that
but anyway by late 1942 he's becoming an
art critic and he publishes his first
review which is in the left-wing
magazine Tribune and publishes it
regularly throughout the war his first
after his first two articles the art had
had changes and it becomes the next
encumbered he's George Orwell which puts
in fear of God into him
and that he will never write again
because he can't write as well as all
but anyway it works out very well and
they have a developer friendly
relationship and his first review is of
an exhibition and at the Berkeley
galleries by a German born polish art is
Catarina village in ski we Democratic
lahontan in 1939 and she's not
particularly well-known now now she's a
makes very interesting engaging in
classicizing drawings that any case the
I suppose the point of saying this
refused to is to say well this is I'm
still Vestas first published work he's
now change his name from Antony
Sylvester he's slowly becoming David
Sylvester but really what what struck me
and when I read this is the incredible
seriousness with which he's treating
these drawings which actually quite
slight things and it's his first review
so he can pause all this knowledge out
there's Beethoven it's true Vince
Keeler's Aeschylus there's Pusan I mean
everything is kind of lumped onto these
poor drawings and so it's highly
pretentious but it's also it's this
seriousness which he really carried
throughout his life and a way in which
he could really I suppose give equal
attention to a range of objects and he
wrote about cricket and horror films in
the same with the same level of
seriousness that he wrote about art and
I think this is something which I'm
seeing as coming from the war this time
when everything was threatened
everything was equally threatened
everything became equally valuable so
the so these are the exhibitions he saw
he started publishing reviews and he's
also going out a lot and and there's a
lot of them quite a lot of books about
and so home in the 1940s during the war
and they're all largely similar stories
of people going out and getting very
drunk and getting into fights and the
milieu of artists and writers including
people like Dylan Thomas and
the Tamil poet Kamban Muthu and also a
quite a bit of impressive selection of
young artists so this is a an account
Sylvester writes of that period and
again this is a bit of wonderful thing
to go and have a look at it gives you
all the information and he's very clear
he's almost writing it for the benefit
of someone giving a lecture about him
during the war so it's a very gratifying
doctor who's come across again this is
in the Tate archives and it's describing
these nights out in Soho during the war
which he describes as a vocation really
the evening began in Soho pubs the
French and Swiss as they were known
these around old Compton Street and it
was here that Sylvester met and his
first real painters now one of the first
pages he met was Gerald Wilde I don't
know if any any of you know about him I
must admit that he was only vaguely on
my in my consciousness before I started
writing about this and have since become
very interested in him and he was known
as a met as the mad artist because of
his wild abstract paintings but also
because he was blind in one eye and he
was he was actually fairly successful in
the early 19th or 40s Kenneth Clark
brought his work and Peter Watson
brought his work Peter Watson was a I
suppose the equivalent of Clark in being
very rich patron of the Arts at this
moment at very different o'clock in
other ways but if your work had been
bought by Kenneth Clark computer Watson
then you were you know you were on the
you're on the way up however this wasn't
the case with Wilde and his career son
went through a progressive series of
disasters but it sank further and
further Minton under anonymity and
eventually he was found dead outside his
studio and I think in the mid-1960s
anyways his paintings and also paintings
very difficult to come across I mean not
many color reproductions I tried to find
what I thought was the most interesting
but this blue dog in a landscape again
only a black-and-white image available
and on the right Lucy and Freud's
portrait of him done around the same
time
now the one of the Articles that
Sylvester wrote for Tribune magazine
will say this F is called
three contemporary illustrators and the
three illustrators work Gerald Wilde
John Craxton Lucian Freud and it's
really and it's quite an impressive
articles which was published in 1943
sorry 1940 June 1944 and a very early
mention of Lucien Freud and have also a
very another kind of step in this kind
of Sylvester is increasingly serious and
impressive engagement with with young
artists and he's talking about him in
terms of a new type of Romanticism which
is very much indebted to Graham
Sutherland who is I suppose that
perceived as the father figure for this
younger generation but also these
artists were responding to the anxieties
and displacements of war on the left is
an issue an issue of poetry London which
was the this poetry magazine edited by
Thanh Binh mu2 this Tamil poet who would
regularly commissioned illustrations
from these artists and just an another
painting by General Dwyer on the right
my reason I put this in here is simply
to throw this wild comparison in
certainly thinking about Lee hormons
paper yesterday comparing Nash and birch
field
I just saw the Pollock in the galleries
over the way yesterday and it
immediately brought to mind for some
reason Gerald Wilde and that's not
simply a by-the-by it's an sylvester
certainly in his later writing about
Wilde and he wrote a lot about him in
fact he lamented in Wiles death that off
the ten serious written pieces about
wilds work he'd written eight of them
but he talks in 1945 about the way in
which Wilde work really is brings to
mind Abstract Expressionism despite the
lack of any particular or direct link
and they couldn't have been a really
couldn't to be knowledge of between the
two artists and also his writing on wire
becomes a little bit like
Berg's writing but this is something
I'll pick up a little later now the
other artist I've mentioned already is
in this article that Sylvester's writing
about illustrators is Lucien Freud who
is much younger than John Wilde he's
he's around 20 years Sylvester zone age
so he didn't he's he's making his career
in London as well at this moment and the
Sylvester discusses this book at poems
by Nicolas more the glass tower
published by poetry London and with
illustrations by Freud and they are
written extremely impressive and
extraordinary ink drawings which
sylvester compares with drawings of
peruvian and Brazilian Indians and I'm
not quite sure what he means by that and
again it's as comes quite excuse me
quite inflated prose you could say I
read some self-portrait he notes in
passing reminds him of certain wooden
statues by hired indians of british
columbia see from c1 then this kind of
wide-ranging style is developing but
he's very perceptive turn he says of
this drawing dead monkey it shows a good
deal of that skill in perceiving and
rendering the particular character of
individual things anyway then the know
there's a add to this group of artists
he's meeting that very important other
free-cos john Craxton and who was
equally young equally making his way in
wartime London and certainly much more
allied with what was later notice
neo-romanticism
and a kind of interpretation of
Sutherland which was darkened by the
experience of war and crack stones -
earliest published works were in the
magazine horizon this pen emboss drawing
personal landscape and dreaming a
landscape and they were published in
horizon in
to Horizon is extremely important and I
thought about actually know you could
really give a talk about the role of
horizon during war it's founded in 1939
by several Connelly
it's who was criticized for doing so
because it was felt that it was a way of
avoiding war services gonna have a bit
of a retreat for intellectuals or form
of an inner immigration which is
interesting because crack stones article
about drawings accompanied an article an
anonymous article called notes on war
guilt which is exactly this about this
team of artists and intellectuals
essentially feeling guilty that they
were partaking they weren't fighting and
it really began to see you'd crack
standar drawing certainly much in these
terms he's this sense of an anxiety and
the form status of intellectuals an
artist during the war now when when
cracks in his home was destroyed by bomb
in 1941 he moved into a studio with
Lucien Freud it was paid for by Peter
Watson was very rich an important patron
and just to bring Kenneth Clark back in
for a second it was here that Kenneth
and Jane Clarke his wife once went to
tea and found that Freud was stored
storing them the dead monkey in the oven
they dead monkey that he was drawing
into cotton from a local pet shop and
for some reason he put it in the oven to
stop the smell going around the kitchen
and anyway Park writes very musingly
about this in some letters at the time
and this studio which is in some John's
word is a very famous bohemian Center
for some reason the entrance hall is
strewn with shattered glass which you
have to walk over as you get to you walk
up to the stairs and John Craxton tells
a story of Oliver Brown from the
Leicester galleries and being greeted by
a naked Lucy and freud walking over the
proton glass in the halls he came down
with his paintings in his hand and
anyway it seems I think he seemed
inevitable that Sylvester would have
gone to this studio because it's just
around the corner from where he lived
but again that's getting me to another
level of detail which detail which is
actually quite difficult to unravel
certainly Freud and crafts and were the
two most sophisticated of the young
artists he met just a briefly mention
another to the to Roberts Robert McBride
amada-kun who from Glasgow can have hard
drinking hard talking artists I think
there's more to be said about the the
with Sylvester but then there's only so
much one could fit in and there is
another very interesting meeting that
Sylvester has this is a real kind of
true vine in the archive and one of his
favorite what I've survived his favorite
night clubs hymns in Soho was called the
night life and it was a basement club in
mr. Newport Street with a bar at one end
and a stage at the other and there's all
manner of Acts from classical music to
drag queens and cabaret this very
interesting sort of young Peter Ustinov
doing I can turn there anyway it was
Sylvester was there in 1941 hanging out
and like chaud else he's doing he's
introduced to a young unknown artist by
name of Richard Hamilton and describes
then going off to Hamilton's flat chest
off Baker Street to look at some well
not itching but dry points which he'd
like to describe and they're these two
extremely early prints by Hamilton which
really extreme very interesting indeed
and particularly because of the way that
Sylvester describes them later on he
looked back and this is him writing
towards the end of his life in his
memoirs describing these elaborate
figure compositions nudes done in line
in which volume was conceived by linear
oval shapes within the forms like
contours on a map which delineated the
areas that would have been highlighted
in a tonal drawing and he but he he goes
on to point out that really these are so
interesting because they show the two
elements that were really essential for
Hamilton's later work and transparency
and a love of systems and also it's
quite interesting that and he should
meet Hamilton in this in the nightlife
participant cabaret bar which was
certainly low life compared to other
cafe royal or someone like that so
they're quite posh certainly for if
Hamilton was later career and as a pop
artist one could say so
this group of painters they were but
they weren't have movement in any way
but they were linked by what John
Craxton described as a conspiracy to go
drinking together and it was and I
suppose whatever wanted me to push on
and get onto which is quite difficult to
Adam bright is this idea that the the
Soho pub culture really had more in
common with the alcohol driven culture
of absolute Expressionism than with the
intellectual atmosphere of Parisian cafe
culture and I so I think in the Indus
millou there's already a sense of a more
of a connection which work with what's
going on west and east anyway by the end
of 1943 Sylvester certainly is decided
he is going to be an art critic
it's very interest in correspondence he
has with Michael hamburger the PERT and
translator where he describes the events
of the latter part of the war he has to
take on workers as a school teacher he
sacked from job after job usually for
having affairs with the Headmaster's
daughter or giving lessons in his
dressing-gown or something like that
anywhere he's cut early useless at paid
employment and here but then gets a job
as Henry Moore as secretary and this
really good is his big entry into the
art world and he writes a very important
article about Henry Warren becomes very
involved with him and this is moving
into the post-war era at that and so
that's a gonna fit I suppose a sense if
it's gonna pick a risk story of David
Sylvester then during the war and I
think if I could have move on to the
second part I want to say there is a
identify emphasized this the sense of
seriousness and gravity and a feeling
that art really mattered Kenneth Clark
was very keen to point out that art is
what was being fought for and certainly
during the war as Clarke regularly said
you know despite all the horrors of war
it was a good thing particularly for
modern British painting the National
Gallery was empty all the our old art
had been moved out and created a vacuum
and it created an opportunity for these
young artists so and they really were in
some respects in the right place at the
right time
but it's I think Sylvester was you could
talk about Clark seriousness in a way
and certainly I think Sylvester was
looking for a different kind of
seriousness this is something which you
can see in his work after the war
there's a wonderful quote quote he says
I was looking for an art that captured
the vibrancy and mystery of appearance
and just a very briefly a bridge
bridging as always brief isn't it but
just to a bridge is what happens after
the war he goes to work for a secretary
for Henry Moore writes brilliantly about
his work and organized as a first Tate
retrospective of Moore's work in 1951
when he's still only 27 but then in 1947
he goes to Paris discovers Giacometti
absorbs the spirit of post-war Paris of
existentialism and returns with it and
uses it to ground his workers as the
champion of Francis Bacon so that's in a
very brief kind of nutshell and records
the famous interviews which I'm sure
some of you know that were published
later on and you know the greatest
interviews art critic artists interviews
of the 20th century there's also another
part to this which is to say that there
was a convert or another gradual
realization honored sylvester's behalf
which was that really this vibrancy and
mystery of appearance was not to be
found in Paris but rather in New York so
if Esther went to New York oh boy that
was I was going to show that slide
before just to give give that sense of
going to Paris find a jack a met Ian and
that informing his work on Francis Bacon
Sylvester went to America for the first
time in 1960 he was invited by the State
Department on travel program and later
said I found in New York the kind of art
life which I hope to find in Paris when
I went to live there in the late 1940s
but which no longer seemed to exist
there and with typical good fortune on
the second day of his stay he was
introduced by Harold Rosenberg to
William de Kooning who took him to the
cedar tavern where he met Franz Kline
David Smith Philip Guston and others and
so that's a pretty good you know first
night in New York and I just found this
photograph online and I like to think
that the figure in the foreground
with with his back to us is his
Sylvester and he's telling these artists
is that I think that's Franz Kline is it
not in front of him anyway he's he's
telling these artists about this
extraordinary young painter in London
with the name of an Elizabethan
philosopher who's got the revelation
revolutionised in the world and they're
saying well no I think that's gonna
happen here actually anyway he'd he
described his conversion to American art
after the war as a a Dallas teen moment
that happens in 1956 when he goes to an
exhibition at the Tate Gallery called
modern art in the United States which
brings to the topic of I mean how much
American art was known in Britain during
the war and how did it become known
after the war I can only convey briefly
say something about that now but the
certainly the it's very interesting to
look at the covers of these two
exhibitions which were the big shows of
American painting in London after the
war both Tate Gallery one of the left is
a was the first exhibition in Tate when
it reopened after being repaired from
bomb damage and that can afford oval
cover is gives a certain idea of maybe
how American painting was seen not
entirely seriously compared on the right
with this extremely austere much more
serious looking cover in any case the 46
exhibition was a survey of American art
from the 18th century to the present so
John Singleton Copley - Stuart Davis the
1956 exhibition was a much more focused
exhibition about it socially about
contemporary painting I'm sorry it's
just gonna really briefly flashing these
things up so Avesta summed up his view
on American painting in 1959 radio
broadcast called the new American
painting in ourselves and this was after
another exhibition of American painting
at Tate which this one was entirely
about Abstract Expressionism and he
writes in this he says in this radio
program how it for him it was only
really possible to understand what was
so unique about American painting by
comparing it with brick
Charlotte ate it go around look at the
British paintings back to the American
paintings and there he saw of what he
called a con thoroughness something that
gets up and hits you in the face and he
took particularly about this painting
Kooning's February as the best painting
in this 1959 exhibition it was and as he
writes the suddenness with which the
paint seems to have fallen on to place
on the canvas the great contribution
contribution of these artists is the
rigour seriousness and vitality and
variety with which they approach her
painting by comparison with which
European art was largely stagnant now
there's a nice you can go back and even
further into the war this is a very
briefly second again a very brief survey
I suppose the most important kind of
early moment of of the story of
understanding American art in there
being at least some kind of exposure was
Clement Greenberg famous essay have on
garden kit which was reprinted in
horizon in 1940 and particularly because
of the way in which you can really reap
luck between lions and say that his
definition of avant-garde and kitsch is
really dependent on a kind of
confrontation of Western European art
and American art or the art of
industrial America Picasso Braque
Mondrian Miro Kandinsky
is the avant-garde and slick and pulp
fiction comics Tin Pan Alley music
tap-dance in Hollywood movies etc etc
our cage now one respects one wishes
there was more in horizon about this
topic there the poet knew his McNeese
goes to America writes me interested me
about it everyone bemoans the fact that
issue would a northern go to America in
1939 and see it is this great portrayal
of the English intellectual
intelligentsia
there is one very I suppose important
article by John Wathan Stein who was the
then the direct with the take
and he spent 1940 in America and he
reported on his stay in an article in
horizon magazine v later that year and
he describes what he saw as an
astonishing nationwide transformation of
the Arts in America he describes it as
leave a on mass which is a direct result
of the enlightened patronage of
Roosevelt's administration which he
describes is the most momentous body of
art legislation in the history of the
Western world and he describes 48 the 48
states competition at the Corcoran
Gallery in late in 1940 as really
showing a new spirit in American
painting a new sense of cohesion and
purpose the artist he picks out for
mention our John Sloan Charles
Burchfield John Carroll regiment Marsh
Paul Cadmus and others although it
should be pointed out but none of the
none of their works were bought for the
Tate Gallery at the time or I think
since the only Charles Burchfield intake
collection is this watercolor freight
cars in March which is so neglected they
don't even have a color photograph of it
so I had to you know you have to go to
the the catalog of non-british works and
see this small reproduction and
fascinatingly it was given by Samuel
Corps told in 1936 anyway so they could
have been this interest but I still
think it would have been a seeing
American art was you know during the war
was incredibly difficult now Greenberg
makes his point again in October 1947
this is very interesting issue of
horizon called art on the American
horizon and I just put the contents page
up on the right there don't know if you
can read it but it some very interesting
contributions we can't go into the mall
but and do have a look at it if you can
I think it's one a really important
statement of British awareness of
American art at this moment
Greenberg's article is typically
trenchant he says that most good
American painters still lived by a kind
of time transfusion from Paris around
1921 so they were still living on the
kind of their explain
could experience and Montparnasse at
that moment with the exception of two
artists Jackson Pollock and David Smith
who are the only artists who did
internalize this lesson of French
modernism and somehow developed their
own idiom but could hold their own on an
international stage we described the
younger generation of the students of
hams Hoffmann making abstract paintings
in cold water flats below 34th Street
but who was still existing in a state of
isolation
he described which he described as
crushing unbroken damming what can fifty
do against a hundred and forty million
he asks what can this small group of
artists do in the face of such
incomprehension to what they were doing
now and so if you were if that's what
it's like in America you know people can
imagine it wasn't much easier in Europe
and Pollock's paintings were first shown
in Europe in 1948 I think that's true
that the fellows Biennale and were given
a largely positive reception they were
first shown in Britain eight years later
at the 1956 exhibition this the serious
touring shows a turbine moment shewolf
1943 this painting and also number one
1948 a famous painting now Sylvester
certainly made up later in life and his
slowness and catching up on the
important and impact of these works and
indeed I think he was probably quite
embarrassed in later life by the review
that he wrote in 1950 of the Venice
Biennale which he was in fact
commissioned by green Clement Greenberg
for the nation their magazine and he
really still verse two really lays into
American painting it's going to I mean
it's not it's only good because it's so
bad his review that is the works of
caught a polyp de Kooning and others
showed that American painting was unsung
unsentimental
and hysteric evidence of an undirected
and undisciplined exuberance and so
Greenberg a commission this view and
took obviously took exception to this
rather wild attack
and he wrote an article defending
American painting and criticizing
servest which basically came down to the
fact that he couldn't use his eyes but
also that American painting probably
seemed just too new for European eyes to
appreciate then as a reply again from
Sylvester when it all gets re ad hominem
and Sylvester I think only ends up by
reinforcing Greenberg's point no I said
at the beginning that I've chosen to
husband hope to shed some light on the
topic I think what I probably conclude
is that I'm not sure the cases being in
the same boat and I think it's probably
more like ships passing in the night
but I think it's what I've certainly
learnt is that the is the kind of
renewed importance of looking at what's
happening during the war and not seeing
post-war artists of a pries of pre-war
art and free all art I mean there's such
a tendency not to consider that
continuity and see the war going to
chunk out of time and it was it was
almost exactly the opposite it was
almost the the most important six years
and there is a another important cited
story and I really must mention this
very briefly because otherwise I'm gonna
called up for not mentioning it at all
which is of course a different kind of
American art that was making itself
known in Britain right at this moment
there's as much culture in a bottle of
coca-cola or as there is in a bottle of
wine an American painter told Sylvester
in 1948 and so if ester remembers this
in an article he wrote ten year or so
years later called art in a coke culture
and he recalled this comment and he said
I simply couldn't accept it I couldn't
accept that there was that there was an
equivalence between coca-cola and wine
coke culture was one of expendability
standardization essentially superficial
in comparison to the the wine culture of
Old Europe and the NZ article by saying
of reverence to the unique object is I
take it the basic moral assumption of a
wine culture which is the kind of
culture to which art can't help
belonging certainly in the work of a
divided palazzi who's making colleges
using the American magazines that he got
from GIS in Paris and from other sources
and late 40s
and certainly in the Richard Hamilton's
very famous collage which is opposed to
the icon of early pop you see a very
different kind of America however that's
another story and I hope you might hear
about more about that later today
thank you very much